[Music]  the only summer  why is it so hard for you to kill this  man  he knew every move of mine before I made  it  I have them right there take the shot  [Music]  and he'd be gone like a ghost  [Music]  who is he  [Music]  I think I know why as good as you  he is you 25 years ago they made you  from me they chose me because there's  never been anybody like me we have to  end this right now  you have all of his gifts without his  pain  you made a person out of another person  then you sent me to killing  he made a choice to do this to me this  thing - you're struggling with its fear  embrace it and then overcome it  of all the people in the world to come  after me why would he send you  you